And with me at this desk,
my personal happy place and my trusted co-pilot,
Rossy Ross Mathews.
Hi, everybody, hi.
(audience cheers)
Hi out there.
May the fourth be with you.
You've got May the fourth and Cinco de Mayo.
(laughs) It's all happening.
It's a great month.
I know.
(audience applauds)
Well, first up in the news,
we have got a brand new gem from the TikTok mines.
Oh, that well, we love it so much.
So you know, dark circles,
obviously, are a thing.
They're one of my personal, hardest things.
Yeah, you've talked about it here a lot.
Well I have dark circles.
Uh-huh.
And Refinery 29 reports
that a new makeup hack can make them disappear.
All you have to do is take your concealer,
ideally, a tone or two down from your foundation
and draw a fun pair of glasses on your face.
And then, of course, make sure you blend,
don't leave it like that.
Basically, what I think this is great for is,
do you know how in the bronzing world
we have the magic three?
This is how you're supposed to bronze,
it's called the magic three,
it's a backwards three on your face.
Rossy, you're doing it.
Of course I'm doing it, hello?
(audience laughs)
Perfect.
So if we have information
about where we're supposed to bronze,
maybe we need the glasses hack
for where we're supposed to conceal?
Everybody needs a facial roadmap.
Bronze,
conceal.
Okay.
Well, do I look better?
Yeah?
(audience yells and applauds)
So hard.
Do you have a beauty blender?
I do have a blender.
Okay, so now I'm gonna blend?
Yeah.
Okay.
Here you go.
I think I'm starting to look pretty great.
Oh God, look at.
No, you keep blending.
Keep blending?
Yeah, you know, just keep blending.
Okay.
Just keep blending.
This looks like I'm preparing
for my job at the circus, right?
Just a little bit?
(audience laughs)
(laughs) Well, if we aren't carnies,
I don't know who is, Ross.
(laughs) How's that look?
Do I look?
(audience whoop)
Oh, I just woke up.
It's good.
It looks good?
Yeah.
And you know, I would never be assy, Ross.
It looks good.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, I...
Hi, it's me.
Thank you for noticing, all right-
Well the magic three bronzer just got a sister
and it's the eye glasses shape concealer.
Try it at home, it works.
My beauty is exhibit A .
Thank you so much.
Yes, it is, Rossy.
All right, next, we got a big question
about etiquette after breaking up.
You know, it's always so confusing after a breakup.
How do you handle it?
Well, The Mirror reports,
a woman posted this on Reddit, listen.
She says her ex-boyfriend wants her to
stop going to his favorite restaurant.
(Drew chuckles)
Back when they were dating
he introduced her to this amazing Korean barbecue spot.
I'm in, I love Korean barbecue.
Who doesn't?
Right?
But now they've split up.
And then he ran into her there
when he was out on a date with somebody else.
And he accused her of stalking him
and asked her to stop eating there.
And she says she doesn't care about him,
she's there for the barbecue.
And I side with this barbe-cutie.
Let me tell you something.
(audience applauds)
I do too.
If there's a place that's got amazing ribs
and you don't want me to go there anymore,
I'll break your ribs.
(Drew laughs)
You understand?
You don't get the restaurant in the divorce.
I'm sorry, you don't.
You don't get custody of the barbecue ribs.
I completely agree, I love,
God, I have such a rebellious side.
I would've just loved if this guy was like,
"You're still into me."
I would've just wanted to kick his butt, you know?
Yeah.
I do.
It's like, "Oh God, I'm here for the meat, not you."
(laughs) I'm just here for the meat.
I'm just here for the meat.
This has nothing to do with you.
It's been a year, get over yourself
(audience laughs)
Get over you.
So I say to this woman,
you just eat, dine, bon appetit.
Absolutely.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Preach, Barrymore.
(bright theme music)